if you love harry potter and animal
crossing then this
is the video for you
[Music]
today we're going to be talking about
the top 10 harry potter inspired designs
for animal crossing new horizons people
of the internet retrorecontour here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
animal crossing new horizons is a
fantastic game for a lot of different
reasons but
one of the biggest reasons by far is how
much room it gives you to be creative
from decorating your own house to
creating clothing patterns and furniture
designs
animal crossing gives players plenty of
tools to make items inspired by your
other favorite fandoms
one of the fandoms where i've seen some
of the best creations so far
the harry potter fandom so today i've
selected 10
of my favorites to share with you now as
we go through each of these i'm going to
make sure you see the name of the user
who created it and i'll also include
links
down in the description where you can
check out the design ideas for yourself
these aren't in any particular order
except for the very
last one which is absolutely bonkers you
guys
an entire island dedicated to harry
potter
be sure and let me know which one is
your favorite idea down in the comments
below and if this gave you any ideas for
your island
so come aboard the hogwarts express with
me as we journey into animal crossing
harry potter edition
now all you've got to do is walk
straight at the wall
between platformers 9 and 10. let's do
it in a bit of a run
we'll start off with hogsmeade crossing
which is an instagram account i stumbled
onto and was immediately blown
away by some of their designs i think my
favorite is actually their most recent
post with weasley's wizard wheezes
there are several fantastic little
details going on here first we have fred
and george here on the right with
sparklers in hand
there's also a stall complete with the
logo and then to top it all off a
screenshot taken at the exact moment
a weasley's wizard wheezes firework
explodes in the sky
just so much attention to detail here
that shows a clear knowledge of the book
series and also a very creative animal
crossing designer
they have so many good scenes on their
instagram page and my second favorite
would probably be
this iconic scene from goblet of fire
number two
diagon alley moving on to another
wonderful creator we have reddit user
bacoon's
take on diagon alley here it all starts
with the brick entrance which we pass
through
and then into diagon alley after you're
through the wall you'll
immediately notice custom have you seen
this wizard posters
there are also multiple stalls with
custom designs and you'll notice how
they creatively place diagon alley
around the able sister shop
there are also some house robes on
display that really help to bring it all
together
moving away from diagon alley we have
number three on our list which
is a quidditch field made by reddit user
critent
there are several things going on here
that really make this design work first
you can see how they've terraformed all
around the pitch to serve as the seating
area
atop the terraformed sections we have
stalls that are all custom designed with
hogwarts house colors
we also have some torches along the back
side plus the field itself which has
been created with custom paths and what
looks like
the sand path the only thing really
missing here are the quidditch hoops
themselves and honestly i'm not sure if
there's
any item in the game that would work for
a quidditch hoop
if there are any of those designs out
there or any item
like that that would work it would
really help to bring this all together
and make it
ultimately just a fantastic quidditch
pitch at number 4 we have a custom
clothing design for hogwarts house robes
courtesy of reddit user possum springs
there are plenty of hogwarts robes
designs out there but what i really like
about
these is how they use different shades
of gray and black to actually make this
look like it's several different pieces
of clothing
rather than just one the house colors
are accurate and they even went the
extra mile by putting the house crests
in the top
left of each row and of course it's the
house colored ties that complete
the look you can also use their creator
code to download the designs for
yourself
number five character outfits if you
want
more than just robes you should check
out reddit user renaxics hopefully i'm
saying these correctly
who has a different version of the house
robes that also include
scarves what i love most about these
designs though are the character
specific ones
you'll find custom clothing options here
that look like some of our favorite
hogwarts professors such as dumbledore
and mcgonagall
as well as some of the most despised
professors such as dolores umbridge
this image also includes a creator code
for you to download their designs if you
prefer
number six honeydukes lily's take on
honeydukes has my mouth
watering for some delicious treats the
colors here just
pop and absolutely nail the honeyduke's
aesthetic from the movies as well as the
wizarding world of harry potter
here you'll find a very clever use for
simple panels that work
really well with the wallpaper choice
there's gumball machines
cakes fruit and a wonderful little
dessert sign number seven the great hall
reddit user steffy has a recreation of
the hogwarts great hall in
their basement or at least a mini
version of it we've got the four
house tables set with dinnerware and the
sorting hat in the middle of the room
there are also candles along the back
wall as well as these little wind chimes
that look eerily similar to the mark of
the deadly hallows
number eight harry potter themed stalls
here we've got an assortment of harry
potter themed custom designs for
the stall item these designs are
courtesy of trickster daniel who also
included their creator codes you can
check out these yourself
as well it looks like we have stalls for
zonkos ollivanders madame malkins and
more as i was doing research for this
video so many of the designs i came
across
use custom stalls so if you're looking
to get started with some of your own
harry potter inspired designs you may
want to grab these stalls because
they'll really give you a good point to
start from
just to help you bring a little bit of
the wizarding world back to your island
next here at number 9 we have even more
custom designs this time from reddit
user nightbound
we've got custom panels to make your own
quidditch stands placemats clothing
designs and even custom signs for
honeydukes and weasley's wizard wheezes
and last but certainly not least
we have big sam 64's harry potter
island that's right making a harry
potter themed area
just wasn't enough for sam who decided
to make the
entire island themed around harry potter
this one
is all about details details details
thanks to the dream address i've
actually already taken a tour and let me
tell you guys i may have to do a whole
separate video just
breaking down all of the little details
here you can tell sam is a mega hp fan
who really went all out to make this
work
truly i cannot even imagine how long
this took to make it all starts with the
hogwarts castle which is set on the
second level of the island
the silos placed on either side of the
house really help to sell the effect
here
once we make our way inside we'll find
the gryffindor common room
there are so many standout details here
but my absolute
favorite thing has to be the quibbler
design on the wall it's just
perfect it doesn't stop there though sam
also has the sorting ceremony diagon
alley
notice harry's birthday cake by the way
platform nine and three quarters
and seriously just so much more guys
sam's dream address is also here so you
can go and check out this island anytime
you wish
i don't know about you guys but i am
inspired by these creators to
get designing i hope you'll take the
time to check out each of them and all
of these wonderful designs
as always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon